you love fly-fishing and I saw these  pictures of you you seem almost too  happy fly-fishing we have pictures of  you here  let's take a look these pictures you  look like the happy you know what I want  you know what I want I want my  screensaver to be Henry Winkler catches  fish and it's always changing because it  makes me happy to see anybody that happy  particularly you but here's the thing  you know it's very difficult to catch a  trout and then when I do I take a  picture I give it a kiss and I sign a  laminated photograph and put it in  smiles because I like to think that I'm  hanging in all of these minutes in the  web when cable is going on dry cleaners  yeah yeah but I fishing it you cannot  worry about anything else in your life  just you and the fish right oh I love it  so much and you're enough gorgeous place  the sound of the water going by it is  the most pleasing sound to mankind yeah  I love it very much